what's going on guys this is rob so we
did our video on the origins and powers
of the watcher which didn't really get
the reception that i was hoping for but
i don't know if it's because nobody
cares about the watcher or because
nobody cares about the idea so we're
gonna do a second video here and
probably maybe a third or a fourth one
just kind of get a better feel for
what's going on but in this video we're
going to focus on gore the god butcher
so who is gore the god butcher well one
we know he's going to appear in thor 4
right so i guess a bear is worth
discussing the origin of gore the god
butcher is actually in thor volume one
issue number six which was written by
jason aaron as part of an ongoing story
arc uh but basically in the thor god of
thunder series so the idea behind this
is that gore was basically a guy who
lived on a world that sucked right life
on this world was rough i mean it was
literally just every day was a battle
for survival against like the elements
predators uh dehydration starvation i
mean it was rough right it was like the
south side of chicago right just a rough
place to be
and so what ended up happening here is
that over the course of his time gore
came to the realization of a couple
different things one the tribe that he
was a part of was highly religious
insofar as they would pray to the gods
every day for like rain or to discover
food or something like that and that
anytime anything good happened it was
because the gods were rewarding them for
their faith any time anything bad
happened it's because the gods were
testing them the other thing that
happened is that over the course of his
lifespan specifically when he was in
adulthood he lost his wife and kids to
any number of things starvation
earthquakes natural disasters things
like that ultimately this all came to a
head when gore publicly cursed the idea
of the gods and basically denounced them
right told his people and even like his
tribal elder the gods don't exist
because if they do why would they ignore
us like this why would we live in such
harsh conditions the result of this is
that gore was exiled from his tribe he
was kicked out but once he was out and
kind of trying to survive on his own and
actually pretty close to death he ended
up discovering the bodies of two gods
who had died in battle one was gold and
one was black now to kind of sidetrack
here at the time this story came out we
didn't know who any of these gods were
who either of these guys were more
recently in donnie kate's run on venom
we actually learned that one of these
gods the one that was clad in black is
named null the symbiote god now let's
talk about him for a second because he's
actually really important to
understanding the powers of gore the god
butcher so null was a being who existed
before all of creation right when the
universe was just an empty void kind of
a funny thing here when marvel makes
this kind of declaration time doesn't
exist at that point in the universe's
history so it doesn't really make any
sense to say null occupied this space
for billions of years or for five years
or for like a year or two months it was
just
oblivion right emptiness there was just
nothing there but at one point in time
the celestials either came into
existence most likely entered that
universe following the defeat of the
first universe and that in turn they
started creating life in the universe
right galaxies solar systems planets
stars people all kinds of stuff and this
pissed off null because he was basically
the ultimate introvert
he wanted to be left the hell alone and
so he ended up waging a war against the
celestials one of the celestials he
actually killed with a sword called the
all black so the the space station in
marvel comics and in the mcu that
floating celestial head that we call
nowhere that is the result of null
killing one of the celestials now
ultimately he was defeated by the rest
of the celestials but during this war he
had basically used the all black to
create something called the living abyss
and the living abyss is literally like
this just kind of blackness almost like
an inky substance that he can control
that's where symbiotes come from in
marvel comics right venom carnage all
those guys they come from the living
abyss technically carnage is the
offspring of venom but it's all more or
less the same thing the reason why this
matters is that when when gore stumbled
across the body of noel the symbiote god
and he took his sword called the all
black two big things happen the first is
that gore came to the realization gods
do actually exist but because of the
harsh environment on the world that he
was living in because of how terrible
things were and despite the fact that
they always prayed to the gods in the
end the gods existed but didn't care the
second thing that happened is that by
taking the all-black necro sword he was
imbued with basically all the powers of
null and so using this he basically went
on a crusade across the universe killing
every god that he could find because in
his mind gods don't care about the
people that pray to them therefore gods
don't need to exist right it's one of
the coolest concepts in marvel now as
far as the powers of gore the god
butcher go it's interesting here while
he does seemingly have all the powers of
no the symbiote god his understanding of
the living abyss is limited so he
doesn't fully grasp what it is he's
capable of instead the only thing he
really did was create something called
the black berserkers these are basically
like what the symbiotes would be if they
took on a form based on what the person
wanted right so gore wanted like these
kind of you know
really
henchman for lack of a better word and
so he fashioned those out of it the
other part of this is that while he
never really had any superpowers in and
of himself in his base form when he was
living on that world when he discovered
the all black necro sword he basically
gained your standard fare of powers
right increased strength durability
speed reflexes all that kind of stuff
but do not let that deceive you to give
you perspective on what gore the god
butcher was capable of this guy was nuts
alright so the first time he meets thor
is when you really get to see his powers
on display right the kind of indication
of what he can do in relation to thor
now there is a bit of a caveat at this
point in time it was during the 9th
century thor did not have access to
mjolnir he hadn't gained the ability to
lift it yet so what he had in instead
was called yarnbjorn basically this
giant battle ax that was magically
enchanted really through the efforts of
kang and loki that allowed him to kill
celestials or at least celestial
technology the important thing here is
that when he fought gore for the first
time gore beat the hell out of him right
he almost killed thor now the whole
thing behind this is that thor came to
the realization that gore existed
because there was there were gods or at
least a god that was killed by gore in
the americas that washed up on the
shores of iceland and then eventually
thor found himself in what was
essentially russia where he found even
more gods that had been killed by gore
but gore was still there at the time so
literally gore beats the hell out of
thor like almost kills him and then
takes him and tortures him for 17 days
during that time you actually find out
that gore tortured the god of torture it
was crazy
[Laughter]
it was one of the most bonkers things
eventually thor's allies in the form of
vikings show up and basically offer a
kind of distraction and then thor cuts
off the arm of gore and then leaves them
for dead right so the belief is that
gore had basically been defeated gore
escapes and then just continues his
crusade to kill gods until he meets thor
in the modern day and then he beats the
hell out of him again right because he
just grown more powerful as time went on
eventually you get to the future like
the far-flung future where you have thor
from the past the present and the future
who all band together right to give you
perspective this is gonna this is gonna
blow your mind and i hope we see it in
thor four right there comes a point
where thor from the present gets the
all-black necro sword right so he
basically has the power of gore he has
two hammers
two mjolnirs and he still can't defeat
gore it's crazy how powerful this guy is
now the whole goal of gore was to
basically create something called the
god bomb which was essentially a bomb
that he would send into the time stream
and then detonate and it would basically
kill all the gods across the timeline
but in that far-flung future gore's
power was on such a level that he
actually launched an attack against
asgard defeated all the asgardians
including thor in the future who
basically had the thor equivalent of the
odin force and then forced all the
asgardians that he didn't kill into
working form to build the god bomb this
guy was a hoss now eventually uh gore is
defeated but then loki brings him back
accidentally and then like this great
big huge battle ensues between like thor
and gore and there's a point where gore
uses the all black to make himself a
universe like literally thor is fighting
a universe now the only reason why thor
won was because prior to that point in
time all life on earth had basically
been eradicated and that it would
basically started to slowly return and
that thor ended up basically asking all
the denizens who were there and all the
gods for their prayers
what happened that's not what you don't
get out of here get out of here go get
out of here i just want to leave get out
of here okay fine fine
fun
i never should have asked my twin to
come on here and make that video
who knows comics better than me
here's what actually happened so you end
up finding out that during jason aaron's
run on thor that in the hammer of thor
is what's called the god tempest this is
basically a cosmic storm powerful enough
to potentially wipe out a whole universe
in the early days of creation odin had
taken that storm and confined it into
the hammer of thor which one was used to
explain why thor's hammer is so powerful
and two why it is that the hammer's able
to select who's worthy and who's not
that it's not strictly based on the
enchantment of odin so
once the whole story popped off and gore
basically became a universe that loki
distracted gore for a moment and then
thor unleashed the full totality of the
god tempest power so in effect gore was
basically destroyed by the power of a
universe it was kind of crazy but the
whole idea behind gore this guy's power
is on a whole different level right once
he has the all-black sword his power is
insane there was basically no one who
could stand against it now a lot of you
guys are probably going to ask the
question nope nope nope nope
now a lot of you guys are probably going
to ask the question how does this
compare to something like the infinity
gauntlet or something along those lines
he's not quite on that level right one
thing to keep in mind the infinity
gauntlet is a really good kind of litmus
test in relation to the power that
somebody has if they're powerful enough
to overpower infinity gauntlet they're
usually on a multiversal level if
they're not more powerful than an
infinity gauntlet they're usually on a
universal level some people are equally
powered to an infinity gauntlet but
somebody like gore the godbutcher is not
he's wildly powerful with the all black
sword but because he doesn't fully
understand the power that he has he's
not quite on the same level as like an
infinity gauntlet but regardless this
guy's more than enough to be able to
take out thor pretty readily but that
being said guys i'm gonna bring this to
an end
and i will catch you all later
peace